[Applaudissements]
la fabrique de nos réalités
qu'est ce que ça signifie fabriquer sa
réalité car le terme m deux réalités
renvoi plusieurs choses le monde
sensible de planète notre environnement
social économique géographique notre
éducation nos talents naturels
la réalité c'est donc l'univers
particulier dans lequel une personne
évolue alors je vous rassure je ne vais
pas vous faire un cours de philosophie
je vous promets non non non c'est pas du
tout le but de ma présence si je devais
résumer le message que je souhaiterais
faire passer aujourd'hui je vous dirais
vous avez les moyens d'agir sur votre
réalité de l'augmenter de l'enrichir de
la créer alors allez-y foncez
agissez expérimenté en vous faisant
confiance à vous un vent avant tout et
en faisant confiance à la vie car la
réalité c'est pas simplement le monde
sensible c'est aussi celle que nous
construisons
mentalement c'est votre alité la mienne
la nôtre c'est nos croyances nos
sentiments nos aspirations
nos rêves donc parler de la réalité
c'est parler de notre univers de mon
univers particulier et sur lequel je
peux agir maintenant tout de suite et
c'est donc à partir de mon univers
particulier que je souhaiterais
aujourd'hui évoqués et partager avec
vous la fabrique de nos réalités
tout d'abord
dans le quotidien dans mon quotidien
d'enseignante et de chercheur à
l'université de lausanne et ensuite dans
celui que j'ai aussi créé en me
transforme en moi même et en
m'appliquant les propres consignes que
je donne à mes étudiants qui feront la
société durable de demain est donc ce
message donc à partir de mon univers
particulier à moi c'est en jouant sur
ces deux registres enseignante et
chercheur d'un côté auto expérimentation
de l'autre que j'aimerais pour le donner
ce soir
alors je vais le répéter ce message
c'est une déformation professionnelle de
radotage qui m'oblige je le répète donc
à jc foncé expérimentés et fait
confiance à l'aise je peux vous assurer
d'une chose c'est exactement de cette
manière que je commence mon cours à
l'université de lausanne cours qui
s'intitule outils et pratiques de la
durabilité dans le cadre d'un master en
fondement et pratique la durabilité
alors en quelques mots clés 1 c'est quoi
ce masters
c'est une solide formation théorique à
l'issue de laquelle les étudiants sont
censés pouvoir diffuser expliquer les
moyens d'action collectif et citoyen
pour accélérer la transition est
justement avant de se lancer
il dispose d'un espace temps pour
produire des savoir-faire pour
expérimenter pour fabriquer pour gagner
du temps et créer les conditions de leur
propre employabilité car à l'issue de ce
set de ce cursus
certains ont peur certains craignent de
devoir délivrer ce message
face à des employeurs des employeurs
seniors peu réactif peu sensible à la
donne écologique à cette urgence que
l'on doit affronter et donc
plutôt que d'aggraver leur stress plutôt
que de leur faire peur j'essaie de
départ avec la réalité de ces jeunes
avec leurs idéaux j'essaie dès le départ
dans une énergie positive de les inviter
à penser à leur projet ils peuvent donc
osé ils ont droit de faire des erreurs
et je dirais même le devoir c'est
fondamental de faire des erreurs pour
apprendre c'est donc un cours pratique
pour co-construire pour créer sa
fabrique de réalité je commence donc mon
pot avec une toute petite question
que voulez vous faire réponse standard
s'est pas trop panique un petit peu
c'est tout à fait normal
alors je reformule je repose la question
pourquoi avez-vous le fer ce master au
besoin je leur demande de me remettre
une feuille de route
comment vous voyez vous dans dix ans et
je reformule à nouveau qu'est ce qui
vous fait vibrer qu'avez vous envie de
réaliser depuis toujours et pour lequel
vous disposez du temps maintenant
j'essaie de les faire se reconnecter à
cette part d'enfants que nous avons tous
en nous cette part de créativité
cette part de rêve dont nous avons
besoin cette part de rêve qui ouvre à
tous les possibles où tout peut se faire
ou tout reste à faire
bien entendu je les coaches également
tout au long de l'année
il m'envoie régulièrement une feuille de
route et dispose également d'autres
outils voilà comment je les amène à
fabriquer leur propre réalité et vous
comprendrez maintenant comment moi même
j'ai fabriqué ma réalité je me suis posé
la question et toi 4 envie de faire
comment diffuser ce message un public
plus large
comment imaginer un futur plus
collaboratif plus solidaire qui lie les
gens dans un sentiment d'interdépendance
je me suis vraiment posé la question et
toi que veux tu faire comment est-ce que
tu contribues à ce futur plus
collaboratif et plus solidaire ma
première réponse fut d'écrire un bouquin
est pas un bouquin qui resterait juste
sur ma table de chevet ou la table de
chevet des autres j'ai pensé pouvoir
expérimenter ce livre le titre du livre
pour un revenu de transition écologique
je suis convaincu que le travail que des
métiers nouveaux son corps entre eux
sont encore vont encore exister dans le
futur je suis persuadé je suis convaincu
que le facteur reste encore un facteur
d'intégration sociale et de
reconnaissance sociale et ce exactement
de nouveaux emplois dont nous avons
besoin pour la transition écologique et
ce dans tous les domaines urbanisme
mobilité agriculture viticulture
marketing finance bank
tous les métiers tous nos modes de
production et de consommation sont à
repenser sous ce prisme et quand je
demande aux porteurs de projets
ce dont ils ont besoin ce dont ils
auraient besoin pour transiter voilà ce
que j'entends en synthétisant on a
besoin d'une sécurité financière pour
transiter pour aider nos familles on a
besoin de guide
accompagnement de savoir par où
commencer on a besoin de se joindre à
d'autres de savoir quelle autre activité
existe dans notre domaine et comment ça
a été fait de quelle manière
c'est alors en réponse à ces trois
freins que j'ai repéré que j'ai proposé
ce dispositif de revenus de transition
écologique dispositif qui donc propose
un revenu de sécurité financière un
accompagnement adapté pour chaque projet
est un réseau l'adhésion à une
coopérative à une association pour
permettre un réseautage ma deuxième
réponse date de l'été 2010 est pleine
vacances familiales j'ai réalisé que
j'avais aussi besoin concrètement de
créer une organisation pour expérimenter
ses revenus transition écologique sans
attendre que les politiques s'emparent
du sujet ce qui peut prendre on va dire
un certain temps - temps certain j'ai
donc créé la fondation the rain zen qui
signifie vivre en grec
the rain c'est ma fabrique de reddit à
moi c'est une structure un lieu pour
informer pour sensibiliser pour aider au
développement d'outils un lieu pour
expérimenter justement des revenus de
transition écologique
par exemple celui que nous finançons
pour un projet le projet terra le
coordinateur du projet terra en
nouvelles aquitaine 1 projets
d'écovillages qui vise à reproduire
localement qui vise à créer des
activités nouvelles dans les écologistes
dans l'économie en redynamisant le
territoire les maisons sont éco conçu la
mobilité repenser le lien social est
renforcée et nous participons également
au conseil scientifique de ce projet
avec d'autres membres d'autres
organisations institutionnelles publics
et privés et c'est donc aussi un bon
exemple de partenariat de collaboration
multi niveaux que nous souhaitons mettre
en oeuvre avec la fondation au delà donc
du volet strictement monétaire et qui
correspond à cette deuxième phase
d'accompagnement autre exemple de
revenus de transition écologique
ensuite cette fois ci c'est le soutien
que l'on fait à une activité de
maraîchère dans le cadre d'une ferme
éducative soutenu dans son activité
la maraîchère a du temps à disposition
pour rencontrer des écoliers pour former
des enseignants et pour superviser
également la production locale dans
cette ferme appelle aussi la ferme aux
minimes 1 et à partir de 2019
nous espérons nous avons décidé
d'expérimenter une dizaine de revenus de
transition écologique en france et en
suisse
concrètement cela correspond à 10
emplois 10 emplois nouveaux dans la
transition alors vous ne direz qu'ils
emploient se sent pas c'est bien mais
c'est plus une goutte d'eau oui mais non
parce que chacun de ces emplois est lui
même lié à une activité clé dans un
domaine clé de la transition
chacun de ces emplois est également liée
à des associations à des partenaires et
chacun implique de nombreuses personnes
actives dans le projet donc en gros pour
chaque emploi soutenu
c'est plus d'une centaine d'acteurs qui
sont indirectement concerné
et en plus ces projets conformément au
troisième volet du dispositif de revenus
transition écologique
nous les mettons en synergie pour créer
une mutualisation des ressources vous
prennez des collaborations inter projet
nous pensons donc que le potentiel de
contagion est extrêmement fort alors
nous jeudi nous depuis tout à l'heure
mais nous c'est qu'ils nous
c'est une équipe de scientifiques
engagés de bénévoles dont les étudiants
des étudiants la première volée du
masters qui ont découvert le projet à
l'issue de leur propre présentation en
voyant que je m'inspirais des mêmes
contraintes que je leur avais sonis de
la même feuille de route
autant vous dire que la sidération était
totale aujourd'hui deux employés 2
étudiants sont employés de la fondation
il assure une partie du comité de
pilotage de sélection des projets à côté
d'un conseil scientifique assez
prestigieux composé de spécial et du
climat de la biodiversité de la finance
solidaire même d'un prix nobel
aujourd'hui c'est donc trente personnes
qui se sont spontanément engagés dans
l'aventuré
zen convaincu de vouloir donner de leur
temps de leur énergie de leur expertise
pour quoi faire
pour fabriquer une neutralité économique
écologique social et si l on fait c'est
aussi parce que j'ai pu les convaincre
mais comment on me reconnecter également
moi même à ma part d'enfants ma part de
rêve à tout ce que je voulais réaliser
depuis très longtemps et cette pratique
de reconnaissions de reconnexion j'ai pu
également la sphère en écoutant les
autres
humblement en m'inspirant des porteurs
de projets en m'inspirant des parties
prenantes qui font preuve je peux vous
le dire d'un courage énorme énorme élan
et cette motivation
cette contagion créatrice c'est celle
que j'avais vraiment envie de vous
communiquer concrètement vous me
demanderez qu'est-ce que ça l'a changé
en moins beaucoup de choses j'ai
l'impression d'avoir des couples et mes
forces
si l'impression d'avoir encore plus
d'énergie et cette énergie j'ai vraiment
envie de la transmettre à toutes ces
personnes
tous ces porteurs de projet qui mérite
en
plus et à d'autres encore alors par
exemple moi qui déteste la recherche de
fonds et je déteste faire ça je me suis
en transformé depuis en spécialiste de
raketa y compris de ma propre famille
pour tout les anniversaires les fêtes
boom au profit de la fondation et de
tous les autres mécènes méfiez-vous ans
que je peux rencontrer autre chose
un niveau plus global plus générale
j'essaie de repenser le problème du
réchauffement climatique
la globalité un niveau plus large pas
simplement au nord et c'est très
important pour la suite des actions de
la fondation penser la suite des actions
du nord au sud et je suis convaincu qu'à
une autre échelle un niveau plus global
plus planétaire pour penser la
transition était important d'agir
ensemble organisé d'échanger nos idées
au delà des frontières
au delà des murs que d'autres
s'efforcent de construire construire ce
que pablo service appel j'aime beaucoup
la phrase l'autre loi de la jungle
l'entr'aide apprendre les uns des autres
en se respectant
construire un nouveau monde plus
solidaire plus écologique pour nos
enfants
ce que je voulais vous dire aujourd'hui
il sait maintenant
soyez votre propre réalité croyez en ce
que vous voulez faire croyez en vos
rêves parce que vous êtes les meilleurs
ambassadeurs du monde à partir de votre
monde à vous agissez sur la réalité en
déployant la vôtre et plus vous serez
optimiste confiant engagé croyant votre
projet et plus les opportunités et
rencontres fortuites
les hasards se présenteront pour
conclure j'aimerais vous raconter une
petite histoire c'est l'histoire d'une
petite grenouille une grenouille qui
participent à une course pour se hisser
au sommet d'une tour
cette grenouille au début elle est avec
plusieurs autres allez sur la ligne de
départ mais au fur et à mesure que la
pression des dés de la foule un petit
peu désagréable arrive arrêté pour qui
vous prenez vous abandonne abandonné à
toutes ces petites grenouilles
disparaissent les unes après les autres
et à la fin courageusement petite
grenouille qui somme toute douce pente
qui arrivent à se glisser au sommet
d'une tour il y en a plus qu'une et une
seule la course alors toutes ses copines
se précipite et ulysse mais quelle est
ta force comment as tu fait quel est ton
secret dis le nous
connaissez-vous le secret la petite
grenouille a été sourde exactement elle
était sourd et n'a pas entendu les cris
elle a suivi son propre chemin
le secret pour fabriquer sa réalité
s'écouter soit suivre son instinct sa
petite voix intérieure en restant humble
s'écouter soit c'est la clé pour
fabriquer sa réalité
alors quel que soit votre projet si
c'est celui qui vous fait vibrer celui
que vous ressentez agissez foncé
expérimentés et fait confiance à la vie
[Applaudissements]